اهلا بكم في هذه النافذه للتحليل العسكري
نستضيف فيها المحلل العسكري اللواء فايز
الدويري وسيكون معنا على الخارطه
التفاعليه الزميل محمود الكن ونبدا معك
محمود تفضل نعم ليلى هناك الكثير من
الاحداث والعمليات العسكريه التي تمت
اليوم سنلاحظ على مختلف مناطق قطاع غزه
نتحدث عن الشمال والوسط والجنوب حيث كان
هناك استهداف للاليات العسكريه في هذه
المناطق على
كافه المناطق القطاع لكن دعونا نشاهد ما
يحدث في شمال قطاع غزه تحديدا في مدينه
غزه هنا من اللافت ان اللون الاصفر هو
لحركه المناورات العسكريه في قطاع في
مدينه غزه شمال القطاع كان في الايام
الماضيه استهدافات بسلاح الطيران هنا في
الشيخ رضوان باضافه استهداف لمخيم
جباليا واليوم في المناطق الجنوبيه لجحر
الديك اضافه الى استهدافات في الشارع رقم
10 مع انتشار كثيف لقوات الاحتلال في هذه
المناطق الهدف بحسب ما ذكره مراسلنا الياس
كرام بانه يتم منع عبور النازحين وعودتهم
الى ديارهم الى شمال القطاع في مدينه غزه
لكن من الملاحظ ايضا ضمن الخطه ال او ضمن
الحركه العسكريه البريه تحديدا ان ال حركه
الاليات كانت متجهه من الجنوب باتجاه
الشمال وايضا من الشمال باتجاه الوسط هنا
وبالتالي عمليه دفع كانت باتجاه وسط قطاع
وسط مدينه غزه هنا باتجاه مفرق او مفترق
الصناعه بها وهنا قامت قوات المقاومه
بالالتحام و استهداف دبابات ميركافا
بمضادات الدروع اذا هذا كان ال عمل الابرز
ضمن شمال قطاع غزه ايضا كان هناك استهداف
اخر للمقاومه في الوسط هنا شرق المغازي
تحدثت فصائل المقاومه عن
استهداف دبابه ميركافا دي 9 وجراف من نوع
دي 9 كذلك في شرق المغازي الجهد العسكري
اكبر هو في جنوب قطاع غزه وتحديدا في
مدينه خان يونس هنا تتركز خمسه الويه
فاعله ربما نتحدث عن ثلاثه في الغرب
والجنوب الضغط هنا من الغرب باتجاه مستشفى
الامل حيث اشار الهلال الاحمر منذ قليل
بانه تم ان الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
دخلت الى ساحه مستشفى الامل ايضا هناك ضغط
من جنوب ا خان يونس لكن فصائل المقاومه
ايضا ذكرت بانها قامت باستهداف بمضادات
الدروع لدبابه ميركافا اذا هذه هي ابرز
العمليات العسكريه التي لدينا اليوم ليله
والمزيد من التحليل معكما ومع اللواء فايز
الدويري نعم شكرا جزيلا محمود محمود ذكر
للتو ان تركيز الجهد العسكري هو في الجنوب
والغرب من القطاع ولكن واضح ان القتال
يعود بضراوه للشمال لماذا نعم هناك جمله
من الاسباب يعني دعينا نقول لا تزال
اشتباكات محدوده من حيث حجم القوه هي
اشتباكات ضاريه لكن من حيث حجم القوه اذا
قارناها بما كان سابقا لا هي تبقى ك اعداد
قليله من الاليات منطقه الشارع عش منذ
التحول في المنطقه الشماليه الى المرحله
الثالثه كان هناك توظيف ناري يومي على شكل
سدود ناريه لان انه استعصت عليهم الدخول
الى الزيتون والى تل الهواء
الان اجرى جيش الاحتلال العديد من
التغييرات ابقى على ثلاثه الويه مخصصه
للمنطقه الشماليه زائد كتيبه ولكنها ليست
متورطه في القتال ليست جميعها متورطه
واللون الاصفر كما اشار هي المناطق التي
تتحرك فيها القوات وليست موجوده فيها صوره
دائمه يعني الان تحركت القوات باتجاه
الشيخ رضوان وباتجاه مخيم الشاطئ لكنها
تدخل وتخرج اذا هذه منطقه اللون الملونه
هي حركه القوات وربما مناسب ان نتحدث هنا
عن الجهد الاساسي والجهد الثانوي فيما
يتعلق به هذا سننتقل جنوبا لو سمحتي الان
الشارع 10ش اللي هو الحد الشمالي لوادي
غزه وهناك محاوله عوده من المدنيين هو
يمنع ذلك اذا ذهبنا الى منطقه الوسط لا
تزال المعارك او خطوط التماس كما هي
عمليات اشتباك وليست هناك اي معارك حاسمه
من كلا الطرفين لانه المدافع ينتظر قدوم
المهاجم اذا ذهبنا الى
الجنوب وذهبنا الى منطقه خانيونس منطقه
خانيونس قبل تقريبا اسبوعين كنا نتحدث عن
ثمانيه الويه لوائين في الغرب وسته الويه
في الشرق تم سحب لواء تم سحب لوائين الى
غير ذلك وبالتالي كنا نقول بان هذا هو
الجهد الرئيسي
والعمليه الاحاطه من مدينه الحمد الى
المواصي الى جوش قطيف هو الجهد الثانوي
لكن تعثر الجهد الرئيسي فبالتالي بدا يجري
تعديلا على تجميع القوات فتحول وال يعني
الجهد الرئيسي لم يحقق الانجاز المطلوب
الجهد الثانوي بدا بتحقيق الانجازات فحول
الجهد الثانوي الى جهد رئيسي قام بنقل
لواء كامل من
منطقه السياج ودفع به من القراره باتجاه
عمق خان يونس فاصبح هناك ثلاثه الويه لواء
قادم من الشمال لواء قادم من باتجاه
المدينه الصناعيه ولواء قادم باتجاه خان
يونس مع الابقاء على قوه صغيره دخلت من
منطقه الفخاري ووصلت الى البوتيك وهل
سيكون للرشق الصاروخيه التي انطلقت بالامس
من جنوب غرب خانيونس اي تاثير على
التحركات لا هي اولا الصواريخ اطلقت من
كما يقال من جنوب غرب مدينه خان يونس
باتجاه وسط فلسطين المحتله انا اعتبرها
اطلق 15 صاروخ تم اعتراض 12 والى غير ذلك
تحدثنا عنها بالامس انا قلت مضامينها
سياسيه اكثر منها عسكريه بمعنى اننا لن
نشهد تداعيات عسكريه على الاقل في هذا
الوقت تحركات مثلا نقول هي نوع من نوع من
التحدي انه انا لا ازال ورساله انا انا لا
لا ازال امسك باداره معركتي بطريقه قويه و
واضبط ايقاع الكوماند اند كنترول وبالتالي
انا قررت رغم وجود القتال بثلاثه الويه
محيطه بخان يونس ساتحدث الصواريخ الى
منطقه تلبي فهي رساله سياسيه تعبر عن
اراده القتال والقدره على الاستمار بال
بمناسبه ذكر الرسائل اذا سمحت لي وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي اليوم كان يقول انه
سيكون هناك حكم عسكري لاسرائيل في غزه بعد
انتهاء الحرب هذا اذا هذا اذا تحقق ما
يقول الان الحديث عما بعد الحرب هل الحرب
انتهت هل الحرب حسمت هل حققت انجازا
عسكريا هو يريد ان بناء على ما نراه يعني
ما واقعيه هذا تصريحه لا هذا بعيد عن
الواقع يعني شمال غزه شمال غزه وجرى بها
ما جرى عادت حماس نظمت قواتها في لوائين
في 12 كتيبه وبدات الان ب ممارسه الدور
الوظيفي الاداري وهذا ما ازعج الكيان
المحتل انه رغم كل ما جرى الان بدات تضبط
ايقاع الحياه اذا هي لا تزال موجوده في
الشمال فاذا اذا كانت في الشمال قد تمكنت
من استعاده الامور ولو بصوره جزئيه ومدر
اذا هي قادره على اعاده نفس الشيء في
منطقه خان يونس اشكرك جزيلا لواء فايز
الدويري وشكرا طبعا لزميلنا محمود الكن